We're going back to Mars.
That's right.
NASA is sending a new rover to explore the red planet...
...and after a seven month journey, it only takes seven minutes to reach the surface.
The landing site is Jezero Crater.
A giant basin that once contained water.
Our new rover's name is Perseverance.
Perseverance will search for signs of ancient life...
...and collect samples for possible return to earth.
This time our rover will not be alone.
Nope! They brought a friend...
...a little helicopter named Ingenuity.
Ingenuity will test the first powered flight on Mars...
...which could assist future Mars rovers.
On July 30th, join NASA in wishing Perseverance and Ingenuity "Bon Voyage"
...on their exciting adventure to Mars.